Jerry Pippin does stand up in a hat that you'd buy at gormless and in corms and
or whatever the that place is called.
Oh, for sake.
Jeremy Pippin, does it stand up in a Ascot and a in a, in a,
in a hat you'd buy from groomsmen and groomsman or whatever the that stupid
place is. Imagine by a had at guardsman and groomsman. What the it called?
Goran and Gunson. Goran bros.
Oh.
For sake. Hats from Gorham bros.
Imagine wearing a hat premium headwear. It's called Nope.
Wear a hat premium head aware.
Of course the picture.
The main picture and the fall collection on the website is a guy staring at
goats. A guardsmen, go yourself. What is it? Goran,
dude, go yourself. Imagine staring at 22 goats.
Ah, dude,
there's a guy SI Le leaning up against the barn. Dude.
Let me tell you something right now.
All photo shoots that are at a barn for real dude.
You're not extra good-looking cause you took a picture near some, Hey,
that so annoying. You got all the layers on and you're near a a horse.
You're not good-looking cause you took a picture near some woods, dude.
That's so annoying man. Photos. You know what? I got a really cool place.
We got it. You know it a place it's just like 20, honestly,
it's just 20 minutes outside. It's near Castaic.
We take a drive and the traffic is coming back is just so bad.
It's unbelievable. You wish you wish you hung yourself, but we'll go out there.
We'll take a few pictures as near Castaic Lake. You know,
there's a barn there and we'll take a picture. There's a,
I'll bring a horse and you'll be good-looking dude.
It'll pop you up a notch or two on the one through 10 scale dude,
Goran. I'm going to get some Goran hats for real.
I'm going to get some Goran hats and I'm going to rock it and I'm going to do
stand up with it and I'm going to kill it, dude.
And I'm going to go on before Jeremy, Kevin, I,
as I walk up and I'm going to go like, dude, this is the new one.
You don't have this one just,
anytime you got designer headwear. Oh dude,
with just a cool casual white t-shirt you know?
Cause you're killing it over in Venice and you got some stupid dog,
some stupid like dog that looks at his breathing problems.
You don't have an album, you know, don't get a Goran hat,
get a personality period. Learn karate. You, you know what I mean?
Look at the names of these hats. Decal,
Deagle, dude, are you me? Look at the name of this one.
Hat it's called your amazing, Oh you piece of, dude.
Look at this dude treat. Well. Cool.
Never been more mad. Why aren't people outraged at this?
Are you kidding me? Look at this hat. It's called Canyon reef.
Go yourself, dude. Do you fish in it? Of course.
There's one called cloud nine. Oh, there's a hat called. Yes ma'am dude.
The only time you would,
the only person who would wear a hat called yes ma'am is somebody who straight
up. Does date rape. This is my yes. Ma'am Oh, this has called the guest man.
Oh really? no dude.
Ni Dean the butcher elevated as a clunky
vodka soda. Oh my
con are you kidding me? This, this has called the, the director, bro.
They're all the called the director. Look at them all for Tema.
Beverly Corleone. Beverly,
come on, keep going. The occasion. I'll do it. That's like,
do you know how much of a cocky go? You have to have to name a hat.
That Thomas Santiago a better man. Dude,
this has hat is called a better man. Patty cake.
This is actually better than when I was reading the names for the bar,
whatever the, let me just read some of these.
So keep it this way though. Don't move it. Players club. Okay, fine.
Dreamboat waterway. Charlie grateful. All right, dude.
Charlie grateful sounds like a rapper that would come out in 1999.
Yo what's up is Charlie grateful
and he would wear all purple. Yo.
What's any way to have a hat that you have a song that's that, that,
that starts with, pardon me? Ma'am how you doing? Like dude,
dude grateful would have a song in 1999.
That would come out and it would start with, pardon me? Ma'am how you doing?
I'm just trying to get a packet of [inaudible] Babbitt. Boom, boom.
And I'm truly grateful. Spell it backwards. BB grateful,
grateful Charlie paver to poop out. Pat dude,
there's a hat called fancy dog.
There's a hat called the new guy and there's a hat called trumpet blues.
All those hats were the NBC lineup in 2004.
I swear to God tonight. After a fancy dog, join
tonight. After the fancy dog,
an all new trumpet blues with
an all new trumpet blues with the guy who's with a guy who's a little
bit Mexican, but not too much.
So white people are watching him on a new trumpet. Blues,
George, new trumpet, blues,
George Melendez.
Really? Linda. Is that what it says?
That's a Mexican is it begins with Mendez, but Lynn uninstalled, new trumpet,
blues starring George Lynn. Yes.
And Monique.
We got the perp. Come on. Let's move out. He's got a
Charlie grateful hat with the soundtrack from Charlie grateful. What's up.
Ma'am how you doing? I'm Charlie grateful to make it go lower.
What are these hat names, dude?
How about the fact that they're straight up 500 hats.
You can buy good. Have 17 and push those.
Just some crazy guy. Just, I got keep mega hats.
Call this to try to grateful man. Like, I don't know. it. Put it out there.
Call this one. The Knox Duncan, right? Holy,
dude. An all new,
the glider after double-take and all new the
glider starring Jeff Stoltz
after, after double-take
starring some girl. That was that.
That was that who's that guy.
God who who's that guy who played Jay? Uh, Jennifer Aniston's
Fran, uh, boyfriend and friends who? No, no, not him. Oh,
that's good though. Tom. Yeah, Tom Selleck would for sure be that guy,
the glider and all new the glider after Barron,
after the bear and all new knocks, Dunkin pie
there, you can put pie after any of these hat names and it will be a, a show.
Mr. Cash PI Southern coast PI bevel
take PI Conrad PI
contrarion PI while the hats, dude,
these piece of hats. Imagine a guy wearing this hat and he's five, six,
God, these hats. All right. Um,
all right, we're going to do some ads. God, these Goran hats.
The probably going to be a sponsor soon.